chers collègues nous allons commencer
notre réunion de
commission alors avant de débuter je
voudrais surtout dans un premier temps
prendre quelques instants pour rendre un
hommage à notre collègue victoire jasmin
qui est décédé vendredi dernier quelques
jours après sa dernière campagne
électorale euh nousous souvenons tous de
son de de de de à la fois de son
implication de sa joie de vivre de ses
sujets de prédlection je pense notamment
à tout ce qui concerne naturellement
l'outreem mais également tout ce qui
concernait l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes très attaché à la Guadeloupe
et puis j'ai en tête également le
rapport d'information sur la santé
mentale qu'elle a rédigé avec Jean sol
et en 2021 voilà et donc je ne sais pas
si c'est l'habitude de la commission
au-delà de porter un message en sa
mémoire mais je propose qu'on fasse une
minute de silence si vous voulez
bien
et je crois qu'un hommage lui sera rendu
notamment ce soir à 19h Solon beaufranc
ainsi que demain dans l'hémicycle avant
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement alors mes chers collègues
je vourrais aussi profiter de cette
commission pour accueillir deux nouveaux
fonctionnaires dans nos services alors
tout d'abord madame Maeva Barbier ici
présente qui va se lever qui était
directrice d'hôpital qui a également
occupé un poste de chef de service à la
direction générale de l'offre de soins
et qui occupera des fonctions
d'administrateur elle aura plus
particulièrement la charge du secteur de
la santé publique ainsi que des
questions de biothique bienvenue en tout
cas madame barbier et très heureux de
féminiser un peu ce service merci
beaucoup voilà je vis aussi accueillir
Mathis calami voilà ici présent qui
rejoint quant à lui l'équipe de nos
administrateurs adjoints après avoir été
lauréat du dernier concours organisé par
le Sénat il s'agit de son premier poste
au sein de notre institution donc je
souhaite la bienvenue
Mathis voilà les
applaudir bien alors avant d'accueillir
monsieur leeloup je vous rappelle que
cette audition sera suivie d'une
présentation de l'application déméire
par les services de la commission alors
soit pour les nouveaux sénateurs soit
pour les anciens qui ont besoin d'une
piqûure de rappel sur le fonctionnement
de
démter et voilà et donc
comment voilà pour le ouais cette
application vous permettra d'accéder de
manière dématérialisée à tous les
documents utiles à nos travaux par
exemple tout à l'heure je vais évoquer
notamment le CV de Monsieur Leloup qui
est sur justement desmétaire voilà donc
c'est important que vous puissiez
maîtriser les contours de déméterre bien
alors mes chers collègues nous allons à
présent entendre monsieur Sébastien
Leloup qui est candidat proposé par le
gouvernement aux fonction de directeur
général de l'Office national
d'indemnisation des accidents médicaux
des infections yatrogènes et des
infections nosocomiales l'ONIAM en
application de l'article
l4511 du code de la santé publique sa
nomination doit être précédée de son
audition par les commissions compétentes
du Parlement sans que celle-ci soit
suivie d'un vote donc il n'y a pas de
vote et je crois que vous serez demain
matin à l'Assemblée nationale
je vous précise que cette audition fera
l'objet d'une captation vidéo qui sera
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et sera consultable en
vidéo à la demande je vous précise
également que vous trouverez le CV de
Monsieur Leloup dans démire justement
j'indiquerai simplement qu'il exerce les
fonctions de directeur général de
l'ONIAM depuis
2017 et je vous rappelle notamment que
l'ONIAM est un établissement public créé
par la loi du 4 mars 2002 relative au
droits des malades et à la qualité du
système de santé il a pour mission
d'organiser le dispositif
d'indemnisation amiable rapide et
gratuit des victimes d'accidents
médicaux monsieur Leloup votre
nomination 2017 intervenit après la
remise d'un rapport de la Cour des
comptes en 2016 sollicité justement par
notre commission et qui portait sur la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts en
matière d'expertise
sanitaire une mission de l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociale est
intervenue dans le prolongement de ce
rapport de la Cour qui établissait
notamment les recommandations suivantes
rappel améliorer la qualité du service
renduit construire une politique
publique d'indemnisation plus cohérente
et lisible pour les victimes renforcer
les moyens d'action en facilitant
notamment les recrutements de certaines
compétences dans le domaine juridique de
l'expertise médicale et des systèmes
d'information ce rapport soulignne
également l'enjeu de redressement
financier de l'ONIAM de réorganisation
de ses services et d'amélioration du
processus de recouvrement des
créances pour commencer je vous laisse
soin de nous présenter un bilan de votre
action depuis 2020 en nous expliquant
dans quelle mesure vous avez pu
poursuivre la mise en œuvre de certaines
des recommandation issue du rapport
précité de Ligas dans la continuité du
bilan que vous aviez présenté à notre
commission en juin 2020 les membres de
la commission pourront ensuite vous
poser leurs questions monsieur louloup
et bien vous avez la
parole je remercie monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénate
j'ai l'honneur de me présenter devant
votre commission dans le cadre de ma
demande de renouvellement dans les
fonctions de directeur de l'ONIAM
l'ONIAM est un établissement public
administratif de l'État sous tutelle du
ministère de la Santé créé par la loi du
4 mars 2002 relative au droits des
malades et à la qualité du système de
santé comme l'a souligné l'ancien
sénateur et professeur agrégé de
médecine Claude Hurier qui fut le
premier président du conseil
d'administration de l'ONIAM au moment de
sa
création cette loi a ouvert une nouvelle
ère en matière d'indemnisation des
victimes d'accidents médicaux la loi a
créé un dispositif original de règlement
amiable elle a également créé un droit
nouveau
l'indemnisation par la solidarité
nationale des victimes d'accidents
médicaux non fautifs suite à la loi
couchner le législateur a
progressivement élargi les mississions
d'indémisation de l'ONIAM aux infections
nosocomiales graves aux mesur sanire
d'urgence au vaccination
obligatoire au dommage
transfusionnel aux victimes du Médiator
suite au livre du docteur Irène Frachon
et plus récemment aux victimes de la
dépaquine suite à la création par Madame
marine Martin de l'association d'aide
aux parents d'enfants souffrant du
syndrome de
l'anticonvulsivant en fait au fil des
années l'ONIAM est progressivement
devenu un véritable paratonnaire du
système de santé selon l'expression
d'anain Michel seretti fondateur de
l'association le lien en matière
d'infection nosocomiale et premier
président de France association santé il
a longuement siégé au conseil
d'administration de
l'ONIAM l'ONIAM est un établissement
public administré par un conseil
d'administration qui a été présidé
jusqu'à récemment par madame Claire
compagnon je tiens à saluer aujourd'hui
devant votre commission son action et
son engagement au service des victimes
pendant ces deux mandats plus récemment
vous avez eu l'occasion d'auditionner
Monsieur François Toujas qui va assurer
la présidence du conseil
d'administration et des trois conseils
d'orientation à compter du 16
octobre les commissions de conciliation
et d'indemnisation les CCI le collège
médiator et le collège des paquines
instruisent les demandes d'indemnisation
ces instances indépendantes sont
présidés par des magistrats qui sont les
garants de la qualité des avis
rendus depuis sa création l'ONIAM a
instruit 95000 demandes d'indemnisation
dont 77000 au titre des accidents
médicaux principale activité de cet
établissement
l'ONIAM reçoit 5000 demandes
d'indemnisation par an l'année dernière
grâce au travail bénévole de leurs
membres les commissions de conciliation
et d'indemnisation ont organisé 225
séances dans les territoires de
métropole et d'outrem souvent dans les
locaux des agences régionales de
santé l'établissement a un budget de 212
millions d'euros 92 % des recettes sont
des financements publics nous employons
119 personnes c'est donc un
établissement de taille modeste au
regard à la fois de la diversité mais
aussi de la complexité de ces
missions j'ai été nommé à la direction
d'établissement en février 2017 dans un
contexte de crise
institutionnelle avec le conseil
d'administration nous avons redressé la
situation toutefois beaucoup reste à
faire et avec la nouvelle gouvernance de
l'établissement nous devons continuer à
agir pour mieux indemniser les victimes
au cours de mon prier mon précédent
mandat l'ONIAM a développé
l'indemnisation agit pour recouvrer les
créances et moderniser son organisation
on ne le dira jamais assez la raison d'ê
de l'ONIAM et d'indemniser les victimes
l'année dernière le montant des dépenses
d'indemnisation
a atteint un niveau record de 183
millions d'euros cela représente une
hausse de 11 % par rapport à 2021 et 13
et une hausse de + 13,7 % par rapport à
notre année de référence 2019 avant la
crise épidémique le montant moyen de
l'offre amiable pour les victimes des
accidents médicaux est passé à 147000 €
il a augmenté de 60 % en 5 ans 95 % des
offres proposé par l' niam sont accepté
cette augmentation des dépenses résulte
des mesures adoptées par le Conseil
d'Administration la revalorisation du
référentiel la révision de la table de
capitalisation et aussi de
l'accroissement de l'activité liée aux
nouvelles missions que nous avons mis en
place concernant la dépquine depuis la
loi de décembre 2016 l'ONIAM a reçu 3817
demandes
d'indemnisation 66,7 millions d'euros
d'offre ont été émises au bénéfice
d'environ 1600
victimes à ce jour cet après-midi 51,5
million d'euros d'indemnisation ont été
versé à près de 1000 victimes de la
dépquine concernant la campagne de
vaccination contre la
covid-19 1246 demandes d'indemnisation
ont été reçues par
l'ONIAM à ce jour 91 personnes ont été
indemnisé à
l'amiable parallèlement l'ONIAM agit
avec détermination pour recouvrir ses
créan faire payer les responsables des
dommages est au cœur de notre mission
c'est un devoir de notre établissement
vis-à-vis des
victimes depuis que je dirige
l'établissement l'ONIAM a émis plus de
10000 ordres de recouvrement auprès des
assureurs et des industriel pour un
montant de 254 millions
d'euros le montant recouvré depuis le
1er janvier 2018 et supérieur à 105
millions d'euros si on prend en compte
les assignations devant les tribunaux
qui suspendent les actions de
recouvrement le taux de recouvrement net
est à aujourd'hui de 85 %. face à ces
ordres de recouvrement les assureurs et
les industriels contestent leur
responsabilité et nous assignneent en
justice ces gueras juridictionnels sont
lourdes à gérer pour l' niam concernant
la dépquine 440 ordres de recouvrement
ont été émis contre Sanofi pour un
montant de 43 millions d'euros dans ce
contexte d'incertitude judiciaire sur le
recouvrement de certaines créances
l'équilibre financier est très dépendant
des financements
public un mot sur la modernisation des
locaux et des organisations qui ont
amélioré la qualité de vie au travail en
juin 2020 nous avons déménagé le siège
historique de l'ONIAM de Bagnolet à
Montreuil ce déménagement a permis de
mettre en œuvre de nouvelles
orientations environnemental nous avons
pu engager une démarche permanente
visant à appliquer les meilleures
pratiques en matière d'énergie de tri de
recours aux outils collaboratifs tels
que la visioconférence ces nouveaux
locaux ont permis d'améliorer la qualité
d'e au travail avec par exemple un local
à vélo et l'accès à une salle de sport
pour favoriser l'activité physique et la
cohésion des
équipes sur le plan social je soulligne
la qualité du dialogue avec les
représentants du personnel à l'automne
2021 nous avons signé un accord CAD sur
le télétravail qui bénéficie à 70 % des
personnels ce respect non seulement de
la place mais aussi de la parole des
représentants du personnel s'est traduit
par un taux de participation de 75 % aux
élections professionnel 75 %. un
indicateur classique des ressources
humaines porte sur le taux d'absentéisme
àoniam le taux d'absentéisme est à 3,4
%. un fonctionnement aujourd'hui
normalisé suite au rapport de la Cour
des comptes de février 2017 j'ai pris la
direction de l'ONIAM dans un contexte de
gestion de crise un plan pluriannuel de
redress été mis en œuvre avec le soutien
du conseil d'administration aujourd'hui
l'ONIAM a un fonctionnement
institutionnel normalisé les instances
réunissent régulièrement avec une
participation très active de ses membres
notamment des associations de victimes
un contrat d'objectif et de performance
a été adopté en mars 2021 pour doter
l'établissement d'une feuille de route
stratégique si l'établissement a bien
progressé sur plusieurs sujets toutefois
dans le prolongement de ce qui vous a
été présenté récemment par François
toujass je mesure que beaucoup reste à
faire pour mieux répondre aux très
fortes attentes des victimes du
Parlement et du
gouvernement devons continuer à agir
pour améliorer le fonctionnement de l'AM
c'est d'abord améliorer les conditions
d'indemnisation des victimes la question
de la revalorisation du référentiel
d'indemnisation a déjà été évoquée par
François toujass devant votre commission
en particulier l'indemnisation
financière des souffrances endurées par
les victimes et le montant de l'aide à
une tierce personne pour les personnes
handicapées suite à un grave accident
médical mériterait une attention
particulière et un accompagnement
financier de la part de nos
tutelles avec l'appui de la Commission
nationale des accidents médicaux il nous
faudra aussi continuer à revaloriser la
rémunération des experts qui sont au
cœur du bon fonctionnement de l'ONIAM il
nous faut aussi approfondir avec les
associations de victimes les mesures de
simplification de la gestion de
l'indemnisation dans le respect
naturellement des règles de maniement de
l'argent public la question du meilleur
respect des délais doit continuer à
mobiliser les équipes avec les
magistrats qui président les instances
il nous faut être attentif à trouver le
bon équilibre entre qualité et rapidité
des avismis et et délai d'envoi des
offres d'indemnisation aux
victimes François toujass l'a évoqué
lors de son audition du mois de juillet
l'ONIAM est un établissement qui demeure
peu connu du grand public et des
professionnels de santé il nous faut
donc agir pour améliorer la visibilité
de l'ONIAM et ainsi faciliter l'accès au
dispositif amiaable l'ONIAM doit
développer ses outils de communication
et nouer des partenariats parallèlement
à l'amélioration de l'indemnisation des
victimes il ne faudra pas relâcher nos
efforts en matière de recouvrement des
créances les victimes ne comprendraient
pas que l'ONIAM ne continue pas à agir
pour faire payer les responsables de
leur dommages et nous devons bien sûr
poursuivre notre modernisation à
aujourd'hui l'ONIAM utilise beaucoup de
papiers nous devons donc nous
transformer à l'occasion du nouveau
schéma directeur du système
d'information ce projet a
malheureusement été différé en raison de
l'épidémie il est désormais en cours de
mise en œuvre il doit notamment
permettre d'assurer la digitalisation
des échanges via un portail numérique
avec les demandeurs les experts médicaux
les avocats les membres des instances
par exemple il s'agit d'offrir au
demandeurs un service dématérialisé à
toutes les étapes de son parcours d'
indemnisation demande d'indemnisation en
ligne transmission des pièces
justificatives en ligne pour accélérer
la gestion tout en garantissant la
sécurité du stockage des données et
naturellement la conformité au règlement
général sur la protection des données un
enjeu de la modernisation consiste aussi
à exploiter nos données pour prévenir
les accidents et améliorer les pratiques
professionnelles à l'heure du numérique
et de l'exploitation des données de
santé avec la nouvelle gouvernance de
l'établissement nous pourrons examiner
de nouvelles perspectives de recherche
et de contribution à la politique de
prévention en
santé apprendre des accidents médicaux
pour contribuer à améliorer les
pratiques professionnel est un nouvel
enjeu stratégique pour
l'ONIAM se moderniser c'est aussi
évaluer la qualité du service rendu et
la prise en compte des attentes des
victimes nous devons par exemple
améliorer l'accueil téléphonique et les
délais de réponse dans cette tive
l'ONIAM mettra prochainement en place un
baromètre et des enquêtes de
satisfaction l'établissement pourra
ainsi renforcer sa capacité à recueillir
des retours d'expérience des victimes
sur la gestion de leur parcours
d'indemnisation et sur cette base un
plan d'action d'amélioration de la
qualité du service rendu fera l'objet
d'un suivi
régulier quelques mots de conclusion 20
ans après l'adoption de la loi du 4 mars
2002 de nombreux colloques
universitaires ont mis en évidence
l'Ance
des missions de l'ONIAM au service de
l'indemnisation des victimes aujourd'hui
je tiens à saluer devant votre
commission le travail des associations
de victimes des experts médicaux des
membres des instances ainsi que des
magistrats et des équipes de l'ONIAM
avec la nouvelle gouvernance de
l'établissement nous continuerons à agir
pour améliorer l'indemnisation des
victimes mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie pour votre
attention et je me tiens à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions merci beaucoup pour votre
intervention je vais donc donner la Rapp
la parole donc à Corine Ambert et Alain
Milon pour l'instant voilà on va noter
les les autres d'accord Corine c'est à
toi merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Directeur merci pour pour votre
présentation voilà je suis au fond de la
la salle comme les mauvais élèves
euh à côté du
radiateur je poser juste une question
pour laisser la parole à mes autres
collègues concernant le rapport remis
par Ligas en en février
2021 qui était intitulé consolider
l'indemnisation publique dans le champ
de la santé enjeu du rapprochement entre
le FIVA et l'ONIAM le FIVA qui est le le
fond d'indemnisation des victimes de
l'amante
eu pourriez-vous nous éclairer éclairer
la commission sur les perspectives
envisagé à ce sujet est-ce que c'est
d'abord toujours d'actualité est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est envisagé
envisageable ou pas du tout et quel
regard tez-vous sur un tel projet qui
résume ce que je vous ai dit avant
d'ailleurs Merci à
VOUS oui àamon allez oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur leeloup Merci pour
votre exposé moi je voudrais vous poser
qu'une seule question vous avez dit que
le budget était d'un peu plus de 200
millions financé à 91 % par des
organismes publics quels sont ces
organismes publics qui vous finance
comment eux-mêmes sont-ils financés et
et participent-ils au Conseil
d'administration de
l'omiam une troisème question Annie
louerou merci monsieur le Président donc
je reprends d'ailleurs une partie de la
question de Monsieur Milon Milon les
ressources propres de l'onian constitué
par le recouvrement des finances auprès
des assurances au tiers responsabl ne
représente que 10 % de son budget la
Cour des comptes a pointé la difficulté
de recouvrement récurrente alors même
que des condamnations ont été prnoncé
par les juridictions alors vous avez dit
que 10000 ordres de recouvrement étaient
lancés et vous avez pointé les
assignations en justice des structures
donc condamné et la durée
entre guillemets sans fin des des
recouvrements et des contentieux donc
pouvez-vous nous dire quel quel outil
vous pouvez utiliser pour améliorer en
fait ce recouvrement donc si le rôle de
l'ONIAM est essentiel pour
l'indemnisation rapide des victimes ne
pens pensez-vous pas qu'il serait
légitime d'investir plus avant dans le
recouvrement auprès des assureurs ou des
personnes condamné alors une autre
question concernant la gouvernance de
l'ONIAM la subvention de l'Assurance
Maladie représente 73 % de son budget le
conseil d'administration comprend 22
membres 11 représentants de l'État 9
nommés par le ministre de la Santé un
représentant de l'agnam pensez-vous que
la composition du C a euh est
adapté au à son budget et aux
contributions dans cet organisme et puis
une dernière question vous avez parlé du
covid donc est-ce que vous constatez de
fortes un fort accroissement de
nombreuses demandes d'indemnisation dans
le cadre du covid et une dernière
question on sait aujourd'hui les
difficultés liées à l'accessibilité aux
soins et la perte de chance de nos
concitoyens est-ce que vous êtes
sollicité pour des demandes
d'indemnisation de prise en compte de
cette perte de chance voilà on va
commencer par ces trois intervenants a
beaucoup de questions monsieur Leloup
c'est à
vous je vous remercie pour pour les
questions madame Ambert donc en réponse
à votre question effectivement donc un
rapport de l'Igas et l'IGF qui en
synthèse plaidit pour une fusion
complète de de l'ONIAM et du
FIVA j'étais très favorable à à cette
fusion pour à la fois pour des raisons
d'efficience de de l'action publique
parce que l'ONIAM je vous l'ai dit c'est
720 équivalent en plein le FIVA c'est 75
et il me semblait que effectivement
avoir deux fonctions support c'était pas
forcément justifié à l'heure de de la
contrainte de la bonne gestion publique
et qu'on pouvait certainement organiser
les choses de manière un peu plus
performante pour consacrer les
ressources je dirais à l'indemnisation
des victimes que ce soit de la miante ou
des des accidents médicaux les moyens
étant contraints il faut être au cœur de
métier essayer de trouver des synergies
en particulier sur les fonctions support
donc avec les ministères de tutelle nous
étions favorables à cette à cette fusion
les conseils d'administration des deux
établissements étaient officiellement
sollicités le conseil d'administration
de loniam a indiqué qu'il n'était pas
opposé à ce projet de fusion le
conseiladministration du FIVA a voté
clairement contre ce ce projet de fusion
et il n'y a pas eu de portage politique
de ce projet de fusion ce qui fait que
les les réflexions des des corps
d'inspection qui étai porté par les les
administrations de de tutelle qui qui
sont présentes aux deux conseils
d'administration n'a pas n'a pas n'a pas
prospéré en tout cas en tant que
directeur de l'ONIAM si les initiative
était reprise dans ce sens naturellement
j'y serai tout à fait contributeur de
manière
positive un pays qui peut fusionner
Veolia et Sue mais on ne sait pas
fusionner des établiss de la taille de
l'ONIAM et et du FIVA ou en tout cas les
ancrés dans une trajectoire dans le
respect de la gouvernance peut-être que
effectivement des des questions lié à la
fusion des conseils d'administration a
pu braquer un certain nombre de de
participants et peut-être qu' avait
d'autres schémas qui préservaient la
gouvernance du FIVA en particulier qui
qui pouvait être envisagé je note
d'ailleurs que dans la lettre de
missission des ministres ce respect de
la gouvernance était tout à fait
explicite mais les réflections des corps
d'inspection ce sont sont clairement
écarté monsieur mon vous m'avez
questionner sur le financement de de
l'ONIAM donc en en 2022 l'ONIAM a
encaissé une subvention de 150 millions
d'euros de l'Assurance Maladie donc qui
en voté en loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale une subvention de
l'État de près de 19 millions d'euros et
a eu des recettes propres d'environ 14,5
million d'euros les recettes propres
correspondant euh au recouvrement
effectif de l'argent des recouvrements
de des créances auprès donc des
assureurs en responsabilité civile et
des industriels c'est-à-dire de sanopini
le moment venu la part de la dotation de
l'Assurance Maladie croî sensiblement en
2022 à hauteur de 81,8 % contre 72,4 %
en 2021 sous l'effet de la baisse en
2022 des dépenses relevant des
dispositif financé par l'État et la
subvention de l'Assurance Maladie donc
elle est bien fléchée elle correspond à
la mission d'indemnisation des victimes
des accidents médicaux et aussi des
contaminations transfusionnelles et la
subvention de l'État
elle correspond à plusieurs missions
d'indemnisation les victimes des
vaccinations obligatoires des dommages
consécutifs à des mesures sanitaires
d'urgence c'est-à-dire les campagnes de
vaccination H1 in1 et covid-19 j'y
reviendrai et cette subvention de l'État
permet aussi de financer le
fonctionnement du collège médiator ainsi
que le fonctionnement du dispositif
d'indemnisation avable des victimes de
la
dépquine
les financeurs sont présents au conseil
d'administration de l'ONIAM il y a un
représentant de la CAE nationale
d'assurance maladie et l'État est
majoritaire au conseil d'administration
il a comme ça a été rappelé par madame
la
sénatrice 12 représentants et il est
très présent dans la préparation des
sujets dans le cadre de la préparation
des des conseils
d'administration alors comment
fonctionne le le le
recouvrement l'ONIAM est est un
établissement public doté d'un agent
comptable donc le service
ordonnateur directeur signe des ordres
de recouvrement l'agent comptable
accepte ou pas de les prendre en charge
donc il faut que l'ordre de recouvrement
soit suffisamment robuste pour que
l'agent comptable l'accepte sinon il le
refuse euh il les accepte tous
maintenant et ensuite l'agent comptable
met en œuvre les diligences attendues y
compris des prérogatives de puissance
publique pour assurer le recouvrement
des créances et donc il envoie des
lettes de recouvrement àian
naturellement et des explications sont
données en face et ensuite il peut agir
ce qu'il se passe c'est que les actions
du comptable sont bloquées par les
assurants en responsabilité civile et
Sanofi parce qu'il contestent le fond de
leur responsabilité dans le dossier qui
a été indemnisé par l'ONIAM et donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est la c'est la
valse des huissiers à loniam donc tous
les jours arrive à mon bureau
des huissiers de justice et me remettent
des assignations devant les
tribunaux tous les jours plusieurs
huissiers viennent pour effectivement
ensuite dans le cadre de l'Agenda des
juridictions contester le fond de leur
responsabilité dans le dossier concerné
donc l'ONIAM met en œuvre des
obligations de moyens conforme aux
règles que nous avons adopté avec la
Direction générale des finances
publiques mais ensuite nous entrons dans
un agenda des juridictions qui échappe
totalement aux capacités de
l'établissement plusieurs fois eu
l'occasion d'aller au tribunal
judiciaire de bobini que je connais bien
maintenant notamment pour discuter du
recouvrement des créances de
Sanofi tribunal judiciaire de bobininy a
une très très grosse activité très varié
h é es étonné de voir arriver à un
contentieux du recouvrement des créances
sur la
dépaquine alors que dans la loi ce
dispositif est qualifié d'amiable c'est
un dispositif spécial de règlement
amiable et donc il a fallu que que
j'explique pourquoi un dispositif
amiable créer autant de contentieux
devant le tribunal judiciaire de
bobini les premières décisions du
tribunal judiciaire de Bini nous
l'espérons interviendront au mieux en
elles sont susceptibles d'
peine d'où l'incertitude
juridictionnelle sur le recouvrement
effectif de certaines créances je
diraiis un mot sur les assurants
responsabilité civile qui sont concernés
par le fonctionnement des commissions de
conciliation et
d'indemnisation cette mission historique
de l'ONIAM fonctionne bien parce que les
assurants responsabilité civile
respectent à 85 % les avis émis par les
commissions de consiliation c'est-à-dire
que le fonctionnement amiable attendu
par le législateur de 2002 c'est tout de
suite mis en place or le fonctionnement
amiable attendu par le législateur de
décembre 2016 sur despquin ne s'est
jamais mis en
place ce fonctionnement amiable sur
médiator s'est mis en place
progressivement après une mise en place
du collège d'experts médiator un peu
compliqué quand même mais parce que il y
a eu des décisions de justice qui qui
ont établi une part de responsabilité de
Servier à côté de celle de l'État qui
ont qui explique qu'il a eu un intérêt à
agir du laboratoire Servier dans le
dispositif amiable à ce jour il y a très
peu et ça a été parfaitement restitué
par le rapport de monsieur le sénateur
clinger il y a très peu de décision de
justice favorable aux victimes je
rappelle des pquin quelques critiques
sur l'onam des commercialisé en 1967 et
pas qu'en France dans d'autres
pays combien de décisions de justice
définitive en faveur des victimes depuis
1967 extrêmement peu en France on a
connaissance de trois décisions en
Espagne combien d'argent dans la poche
des victimes du système judiciaire non
seulement français mais européen et
au-delà pratiquement pas tout est en
appel et pas définitivement jugé pas
définitivement
jugé le bilan du dispositif amiable que
vous avez créé au niveau du Parlement
c'est à aujourd'hui 51,5 million d'euros
qui ont changé la vie de 1000 victimes
1000 victimes alors je sais que et les
associations de victimes sont dans leur
rôle quand elles disent que le montant
des indemnisation n'est pas celui
qu'elle pourrait obtenir devant les
juridictions mais je dis attention il y
a des avocats qui mettent beaucoup
d'euros dans les yeux qui disent que de
toute façon ils vont gagner dans les
tribunaux que ces affaires ne sont pas
si simples que le législateur a créé des
règles spéciales avec un dispositif de
règlement amiable très spécifique avec à
la despquin avec un collège d'experts
qui est bienveillant dans l'instruction
des demandes qui fait qu'un certain
nombre de demandes qui sont acceptées
par ce collège d'experts des Paquin
placé auprès de l'ONIAM il n'est pas
certain que le moment venu dans le
corpus de règles médicau-légales qui
s'impose et des règles de prescription
fort complexe dans ce champ des produits
de santé et bien nous ne sa savons pas
quel peut-être le succès à la fois des
démarches des victimes devant les juges
et malheureusement le succès des actions
en demande de recouvrement de ces
créances d'argent public j'ai donné le
chiffre 43 millions d'euros à ce jour
mais c'est pas fini et bien nous nous
nous le verrons bien et donc il est la
responsabilité du Directeur de l'ONIAM
de faire part de cette incertitude sur
ce recouvrement effectif des des
créances vous m'avez invité à dire un
petit mot sur la campagne de vaccination
covid-19 donc à aujourd'hui comme je
vous l'ai indiqué l'ONIAM a reçu 1246
demandes d'indemnisation
amiable nous avons reçu au mois de
septembre 78 nouvelles
demandes au 30 septembre l'ONIAM a
adressé 344 décisions donc 48 au mois de
septembre et donc sur les 1246 demandes
d'indemnisation réceptionné à
aujourd'hui 112 offres ont été notifié
soit provisionnelle incomplète partielle
ou définitive et 232 demandes ont fait
l'objet d'une décision de rejet comme
l'a indiqué François toujaz devant votre
commission les troubles indemnisés sont
principalement à hauteur de 48 % des
myocardit et
pierricardit au 30 septembre 2023
l'ONIAM s'est prononcé sur droit
indemnisation des demandeurs dans
dossier dont 29 % en faveur d'une
adisation et donc à cette date 91
victimes ont été
indemnisé aujourd'hui nous
avons 114 missions d'expertise médicale
en cours dans toute la
France et dans la typologie des troubles
rapportés nous avons donc 279 de
troubles cardiaque donc 202 au titre
d'un myocardite et péricardite 229 lié à
des troubles neurologiques et je ne vous
détaille pas les les
différents si l'on regarde ce qui se
passe au contentieux puisque c'est
l'ONIAM qui est mis en
cause et qu'on regarde si ce dispositif
amiable remplit sa fonction dans le
système et bien au 30 septembre 2023
l'ONIAM a connaissance de 53 procédures
contentieuses 53 actions devant la
justice
1200 46 demande d'indemnisation amiable
devant
leam le montant moy
d'indemnisation et de l'ordre de 8000 €
pour les personnes qui à ce jour ont été
indemnisées le covid c'est les dommages
liés à la campagne de vaccination c'est
aussi comme vous l'avez indiqué des
questions posées sur des infections
nosocomianes en établissement de
santé devant les commissions de
conciliation et d'indemnisation qui sont
compétentes pour l'instruction c'est
c'est un peu plus de 300 demandes qui
ont sont en qui ont été déposé auprès de
de ces instances et donc nous sommes
amenés à nous prononcer sur ces
situations puisque effectivement
l'infection nosocomiale répond une
définition classique à l'occasion d'une
prise en charge en établissement de
santé et donc avec des questions posées
qui est que dans un contexte général
d'épidémie cette notion d'infection
nosocomiale comment peut-elle avoir un
impact sur l'indemnisation des personnes
hospitalisées et si elles sont
hospitalisées naturellement c'est parce
qu'elles ont un état de santé qui le
justifie bien alors j'ai ensuite de
nouveau quatre collègues sénateurs
Véronique
Guillotin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur Général moi j'ai
deux questions je voulais revenir sur le
les indemnisations de la deppquine alors
vous l'avez un petit peu évoqué mais je
vais tout de même reposer la question
donc la commission des finances du Sénat
en septembre 2022 a fait un rapport qui
était euh qui a mis en lumière tout
simplement des des failles du dispositif
en exprimant clairement une sous enfin
des des sous-exécutions euh budgétaire
qui était assez importante avec des des
raisons comme les indemnités versées
vous l'avez dit inférieure à celle
qu'accorde les juridictions civiles mais
également la complexité dans la
procédure pour les familles ou les
retards dans l'indemnisation par exemple
alors ce rapport est avancer quelques
pistes pour y remédier euh moi la
question était assez simple est-ce que
depuis euh la publication de ce r ou
depuis les chiffres de 2021 plutôt il y
a eu des des améliorations dans le
traitement des dossiers dans ce domaine
et dans le plus particulièrement donc
pour le cas de la deppquine mais
peut-être de manière plus générale parce
qu'en 2020 vous aviez également dit que
la réorganisation permettrait
d'améliorer les pratiques
d'indemnisation et enfin une deuxième
question peut-être un peu plus large
concerne l'intelligence
artificielle on l'intelligence
artificielle se développe sur tous les
pans en fait de la la de la santé que ce
soit du diagnostique voir peut-être du
traitement et et de l'accès aux soins
également comment comment ça s'est pris
en compte dans la réflexion des
indemnisations en cas de de de problèm
notamment bah par le biais de
l'intelligence artificielle justement
très bien Céline
brullin merci président merci Monsieur
le Directeur une inquiétude et deux
questions la première inquiétude c'est
que vous confirmez que la fusion entre
l'ONIAM et le FIVA n'est pas
complètement derrière nous euh et vous
le confirmez à partir
de d'une volonté qu'on qu'on peut
comprendre en tout cas certains l'assume
à juste
titre du contexte financier des finances
publiques dans lequel on est aujourd'hui
or vous en parallèle vous montrez que
notamment avec la
multiplication des procédures
judiciaires auxquelles vous faites face
dans la
période le contexte financier qui est le
vôtre peut être fragilisé donc est-ce
que est-ce qu'il n'y a pas à regarder de
nouvelles sources de financement des
deux organismes et est-ce que la fusion
n'est pas une fausse bonne idée qui
contribuerait peut-être à en réduire la
voilure pour l'un et l'autre et dernière
question vous avez évoqué à juste titre
la nécessité de simplification parce
qu'en effet on voit qu'il y a des délais
qui sont parfois un peu longs très longs
même pour des indemnisations et vous
avez notamment évoqué la digitalisation
et la dématérialisation on sait que
c'est un souci pour nombre de nos
concitoyens et on cite souvent les plus
anciens mais pas seulement il y a aussi
beaucoup de jeunes qui peuvent être tout
à fait geek par certains aspects mais
qui ont les pire difficulté pour pour se
débrouiller dans les démarches
administratives euh quelles sont ces
pistes de simplification et quel
accompagnement en présence humaine
notamment envisagez-vous pour que tout
le monde ait accès à ces ses droits
merci merci maintenant Laurence
müerbrun merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur Général euh je
revenais donc sur la dépquine euh ma
collègue l'a évoqué juste avant euh le
le nombre de dossiers déposés à l'ONIAM
environ 850 en milieu d'année 2022 et 1s
en dessous en fait euh du nombre
d'enfants qui souffriraient des
molformation euh et connaîtrait des des
troubles du développement quelle sera
votre politique en matière d'information
des victimes hein et une deuxième
question donc concernant les
indemnisations des victimes de la
vaccination du covid-19 vous avez donné
des chiffres de dossiers reçus vous avez
parlé des myocardiques des péricardites
qu'en est-il des thromboses des embolies
pulmonaires euh qui on qui ont fait
suite à des vaccinations en en centre de
vaccination et non pas à l'hôpital
peut-être hein puisque là il y a pas de
maladie neucosomiale et comment quel est
le budget provisionné pour dédommager
ces victimes puisque j'ai cru comprendre
que sur les 200 millions d'euros qui ont
sont consacrés pour l'essentiel à
l'indemnisation des victimes d'accidents
médicaux et de celle de la dépquine
alors qu'est-ce qu'il resterait pour les
victimes de la vaccination covid-19
merci Jean sol
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le le
directeur bonjour moi je je reviens sur
la sur les dommages liés à la dépquine
sur sur laquelle j'ai quelques questions
vous annonciez donc 1200 demandes
d'indemnisation et 81
personnes dédommagé ce qui ce qui relève
enfin ce qui représente un faible
pourcentage et vous évoqueiez qu'il y
avait 444 440 plainte contre Sanofi
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce
qu'il en est au final et dans le le dans
le processus donc il y a un processus
d'instruction de l'indemnisation il y a
la phase d'indemnisation et dans cette
phase d'indamnisation donc vous
retournez si j'ai bien compris contre
ceux qui sont a priori responsables en
tout cas de de de ces
dommages comment les choses se passent
et j'ai une autre question concernant
les les crédits qui sont dédiés au
dispositifs d'indamnisation sauf erreur
de ma part euh ils ne sont pas en tout
cas utiliser au
montant qui qui vous est attribué
pourquoi est-ce que vous pouvez est-ce
que vous pouvez nous nous en dire un mot
s'il vous plaît
merci je continue hein les interventions
qualifé qualifé merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur je
voulais avant tout vous vous remercier
pour ce votre travail et saluer cette
création loniam pour un ancien médecin
que je suis je l'ai vu arriver avec
beaucoup beaucoup de bonheur parce que
c'est vrai que ça nous a aidé dans
beaucoup beaucoup de situations et je
voulais saluer ce travail ma ma question
aujourd'hui pour ne pas revenir sur ce
qui a été dit comment se passent les
expertises et quel type d'experts vous
avez c'est des experts auprès des
tribunaux ou c'est les experts qui sont
agréés par
l'ONIAM an Amon de nouveau oui merci
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur je vous
pose pas la question parce que vous
pouvez pas me répondre
mais je je je pose je pose la question à
mes collègues je par là euh la Cour des
comptes au mois de juillet dernier nous
a annoncé que l'assurance maladie
finançait les agences à hauteur de 6
milillards 500 millions vous venez de
nous dire nous que l'assurance maladie
finance l'ONIAM à hauteur de 150
millions sur les sur les un peu plus de
200 millions que vous recevez de
financement de public est-il normal dans
C ces conditions que l'assurance maladie
dont les déficits sont dans les bonnes
années 1 mliard 5 les mauvaises années 6
à 7 milliards continue de financer des
agences dans laquell elle ne prend
aucune décision est-il normal par
exemple que vous soyez nomé par le
gouvernement et non pas par l'assurance
maladie et dans ces conditions serait-il
normal que ces agences ou soient dirigé
par l'assurance maladie ou mieux que
l'assurance malandie ne les finance plus
que l'État les finance et que
l'assurance maladie retrouve a des
comptes à
l'équilibre TR bien vous avez compris
que pour la dernière question vous avez
un joker potentiel he voilà je vous
laisse
répondre je la prendrai quand même parce
qu'elle me elle m'intéresse
beaucoup donc merci de de de de me
donner l'occasion de de revenir sur un
un certain nombre de
points donc alors il y a pas d'annonce
hein sur la fusion oniam FIVA donc
peut-être que je simplement demander mon
avis personnel donc je je me suis permis
de de vous le donner en toute
simplicité confirme que pour moi ça
faisait sens dans dans Act alors soyez
rassurés de toute façon toute fusion ça
passe par la loi donc vous êtes les les
gardiens de cette
affaire au contrat d'objectif et de
performance de l'ONIAM donc qui est en
cours était demandé aux deux
établissement d'expertiser des modalités
possibles de rapprochement j'ai
d'excellentes relations avec mon
collègue du FIVA qui est un très grand
professionnel nous avons des échanges
entre nous des échanges professionnels
et on essaie de nourrir nos pratiques
professionnelles des bonnes pratiques de
de l'un et de l'autre et c'est quelque
chose je crois qu'il faut garder après
ces épisodes parfois un peu difficiles
de de projets de fusion qui qui n'ont
pas prospéré et l'histoire dira s'il
faut reprendre avec quellees conditions
et quelle garantie à donner notamment
aux association de victimes pour pour
les conditions d'indemisation des
victimes rappelle que les conseils
administ sont compétents pour fixer le
le référentiel d'indemnisation et au
conseil d'administration de du FIVA ce
n'est pas l'état qui est majoritaire
alors que au conseil d'administration de
de loniam c'est l'État qui a le dernier
mot et donc ça change considérablement
la donne et on peut comprendre ça
sousève un certain nombre de
questions des des questions posées sur
les les autres sources de de financement
je pense que effectivement au-delà du
financement on dame loi de finance et de
l'action recouvrement
une réflexion pourrait avoir lieu sur
l'indemnisation des risques sérials des
produits de
santé je pense que l'ONIAM a acquis de
l'expérience à l'occasion du Médiator et
de la dépquine je pense que toute
activité
industrielle par nature présente des
risques et je pense que sur cette
question importante des produits de
santé des dispositifs
médicaux une réflexion avec les
fédérations
professionnelles un peu indépendant de
la responsabilité de tel ou tel
industriel sur tel ou tel produit de
santé ou dispositifs
médicaux ça mériterait d'être réfléchi
il y a eu des des des tentatives en ce
sens au cours des dernières années on
voit à aujourd'hui que ces
sujets deviennent très
politiques et peut-être que de
manière apaisé des discussions
mériteraient d'être porté euh avec le
LEM avec les autres fédérations en tout
cas avec la nouvelle gouvernance de de
l'ONIAM nous sommes disposés à apporter
l'expérience acquise sur ces
sujets on na pas parlé des sûs mais il
peut y avoir aussi he dans les
dispositifs médicaux un certain nombre
de sujets et il y en aura de plus en je
dirais que la pharmacovigilance au
niveau national et au niveau européen a
tendance à s'améliorer quand on voit la
manière dont l'intellig inigence
artificielle peut être utilisé sur les
centres de
pharmacovigilance ça devient de manière
intéressante et c'est protecteur de la
population et donc des signaux sont
susceptibles d'apparaître et c'est aussi
lié je dirais à l'innovation attendu par
la population sur ces sujets des
produits de santé et donc certainement
avoir une réflexion avec France
association santé qui fédère les
associations de de victimes en France
sur ces sujets c'est c'est le sujet en
fait de la confiance dans le système de
santé et comment si jamais des risques
apparaissent notamment des risques
sériels et bien nous avons réfléchir à
des mécanismes d'indemnisation
simple non
juridictionnel mais qui permettent
d'apporter la réparation financière
auquell les les victimes ont ont
droit concernant la la deppakine merci
de me donner occasion de revenir sur le
rapport de monsieur le sénateur
clinger effectivement au moment de de de
l'écriture de la loi donc c'était
courant 2016 un certain nombre de
prévisions aent été faites donc des
modèles de prévision sur à la fois le
nombre de victimes et les financements à
attendre donc il y a des rapports qui
ont été faits avec les données qui qui
étit disponiblebl à l'évidence ces
modèles prévisionnistes
euh ne se sont pas confirmés au regard
du nombre de demandes d'indemnisation
puisqu'il y a un écord tout à fait
important entre les deux alors est-ce
lié à un manque
d'information sur le dispositif placé
auprès de l'ONIAM alors il y a eu
beaucoup de communication qui a été
faite notamment par le ministère de la
Santé la Direction générale de la santé
et nous avons participé en tant que
oniam à ces actions
d'information la Pessac présidé par
madame Martin que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure fait beaucoup de communication
sur ce sujet depuis la création de de
cette association y compris dans la
presse quotidienne R régionale plus ou
moins positive la
communication mais en tout cas ce que
nous savons c'est que au moment où nous
avons installé au niveau de l'ONIAM au
début il y avait deux instances il y
avait un un comité d'indemnisation et un
collège
d'expert et nous avons donc organisé
avec les les magistrats indépendants de
ces deux instances des auditions
et la Pessac
association consacrée à ce sujet nous
avait annoncé 4800 demandes
d'indemnisation à aujourd'hui en gros
nous avons nous avons en instruction où
nous avons traité les demandes connues
de la Pessac qui viennent puisque je le
rappelle contrairement aux accidents
médicaux il n'y a pas un seuil de
gravité pour être éligible au dispositif
spécial de laadpquine mais toute demande
même pas même pas grave peut-être
instruite devant ce dispositif des
Paquin alors et ça c'est très bien
décrit par le rapport de Monsieur
clinger dans l'architecture du
dispositif tel qu'elle a été conçu en
2016 c'est complexe c'est complexe et
sur des Paquin on fait des choses qu'on
n pas du tout fait sur
médiator c'est-à-dire que dans chaque
demande d'indemnisation le collège
contrairement au médiateor qui n'est pas
composé que de médecins principalement
de médecins le collège d'ext il a des
pquin est composé à parité entre des
juristes universitaires et des médecins
et c'est présidé par un magistrat et
dans chaque dossier chaque demande
d'indemnisation est questionner la
responsabilité de tout le monde ce que
fait pas le collège
médiator et donc dans chaque demande on
va s'interroger d'une part sur
l'imputabilité des dommages quels sont
les dommages strictement imputables à la
despquin et ensuite le collège va
s'interroger est-ce la faute du médecin
prescripteur est-ce la faute de l'État
ou est-ce la faute des laboratoires puis
qu'il peut y avoir aussi des
génériqueurs des des des laboratoireil
et dans une demande il va y avoir des
qutités de responsabilités qui vont être
fixé et donc l'avis qui s'impose au
directeur d'oniam de par la
loi fixe voilà indemnisation voilà voilà
les préjudices donc pour donner
l'exemple de la demande d'indemnisation
euh
la moins élevée que j'ai eu à gérer
c'était une demande d'indemnisation pour
un préjudice esthétique
temporaire pour lequel il y a une part
de responsabilité de 30 1/3 l'État 1/ers
le médecin et 1/ers
Sanofi le montant de l'animisation 1000
€. donc je paye pour 333 € au titre de
l'État ça c'est c'est la partie facile
de la mission dé caisser payé au nom de
l'État ça on sait faire he
mais ensuite alors cafit l'assureur
c'est l'un des je crois qu'il y a deux
dossiers que les assurants
responsabilité civile ont indemnisé à
l'amiable sur des paquines dont celui-là
l'assureur a regardé combien lui coûtera
un avocat pour contester les 333 € il a
payé mais sanofi a contesté a contesté
parce que sanofi a une position ferme
qui avait été présenté au Parlement au
moment de la création du dispositif la
position de sanofier de dire c'est la
justice qui dira la vérité en cette
affaire position de sofice c'est pas de
dire il y a un dispositif de règlement
amiable créé par la volonté législateur
et on va voir comment s'arranger devant
l'instance de l'AM non Sanofi considère
que cette affaire doit être traitée
devant le juge et que donc tout ordre de
recouvrement quel que soit son montant y
compris un montant
modique leur avocat leur coûte plus cher
s'ans
doutter ils
contesteront à ce jour mais jeis allé au
bout du du sujet à ce jour je l'ai dit
il n'y a pas de décision définitive qui
établisse une part de responsabilité une
responsabilité du laboratoire Sanofi en
cette
affaire je suis très attentif aux
déclarations des dirigeants de
Sanofi très attentif notamment à ce qui
est dit devant les assemblées générales
des
actionnaires j'ai entendu que si des
décisions de justice intervenaientent et
qui reconnaissaient la responsabilité de
i à ce moment-là ce
groupe qui a aussi une politique en
responsabilité sociale et
environnemental la RSE comme tout grand
groupe du CAC 40 pourrait effectivement
agir vis-à-vis des victime donc je suis
un directeur de l'ONIAM qui reste
optimiste sur cette
mission je suis très attentif à toutes
les décisions de justice qui sont
rendues en France et je vous l'ai dit en
Espagne aussi de voir comment le
laboratoire Sanofi est son
assureur puisque sanofi a un assureur
qui intervient aussi quand je dis qu'il
y a une complexité de nos missions je je
je je me permets de de les décrire et et
donc nous nous verrons à l'avenir
comment on est ou pas en capacité de
faire bouger les lignes de par la
volonté du législateur qui a affirmé sa
volonté de faire fonctionner ce
dispositif amiable un montant important
de pénalité est susceptible d'être euh
accordé par le juge dans le cadre du
recouvrement des créances de loniam 50 %
de pénalité donc c'est c'est supérieur à
ce qui est susceptible d'être accordé
euh dans le casadre du recouvrement des
créances sur les accidents médicaux où
le juge ne peut nous donner que 15 %
donc c'est aussi un message politique
très fort du du Parlement qui souhaite
faire fonctionner ce dispositif amiable
et bien écoutez euh moi je je suis euh
effectivement mis en cause dans les
procédures du contentieux du
recouvrement et devant le juge nous ver
comment Esser d'avancer pour obtenir ce
remboursement d'argent public je
rappelle à ce jour 43 millions d'euros
et c'est pas fini il rest 10 minutes si
vous voulez bien parort dernière
question
poser sur le
covid alors je
vais je me doutais que ce sujet vous
intéresserait donc sur les 91 victimes
indemnisées
48 % péricardite ou myocardite 11 % de
troubles neurologiques 9 % AVC thrombose
embolie pulmonaire 4 % des troubles
articulaires 4 % troubles dermatologiqu
et le restant ce sont des des troubles
des troubles
divers alors le le budget donc il faut
être je suis complètement rassurant sur
ce ce sujet l'ONIAM a tous les moyens
finan ci pour indemniser les victimes du
du covid des des des clauses de
financières sont en place avec le
ministère de la Santé j'ai rencontré
dans le cadre de la préparation de la
loi de finances donc les rapport
spéciaux sur ces sujets-là l'ONIAM a les
moyens d'indemniser d'exercer cette
mission il n'y a pas de difficulté je
dirais à à aujourd'hui cette mission ne
représente pas des décaissements
importants de de notre établissement je
vlaai indiquer c'est en moyenne 8000 €
pour les personnes qui sont indemnisées
et on est nécessairement sur une
instruction des demandes d'indemnisation
qui font qu'on ce sera lissé dans le
cadre des des travaux budgétaires et
donc là je suis complètement rassurant
sur le fait que notre établissement
dispose du budget pour exercer cette
mission d'indemnisation il y a aucune
aucune incertitude sur ce
point
je voudrais vous remercier monsieur le
sénateur en tant que médecin d'avoir
salué le le travail de de l'ONIAM la
dernière fois que j'ai eu ce
remerciement c'était quand
j'étais entendu par la société française
de
gastro-entérologie puisque pour les
accidents médicaux depuis 20 ans les
assureur en responsabilité civile
médicale jouent pleinement le jeu ils
suivent les avis alors qu'ils n'y sont
pas obligé mais il suivent les avis à 85
% et donc ce dispositif amiable la
conséquence c'est les cotisations
d'assurance professionnelle des médecins
y compris des spécialités à risque
n'augmente pas et sont contenus et donc
l'existence des CCI et de l'ONIAM
favorise l'exercice de la médecine en
France depuis 20
ans les experts que nous nous mobilisons
sont inscrits sur la liste nationale de
la Commission nationale des accidents
médicaux et également sur la liste des
cours d'appel et donc nous avons des des
des milliers de de de médecins qui
contribuent
à au bon fonctionnement de ce dispositif
amiable et Monsieur man je votre
question extrêmement intéressante
l'ONIAM est l'ONIAM est créé dans le
dans le code de la santé publique sur la
partie risque inhérent au fonctionnement
du dispositif de santé et donc il y a
une certaine logique à faire financer
par l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie des risques liés à
ce fonctionnement des des du du du
système de
santé et j'ai eu l'occasion d'être
entendu par la mex récemment pour
effectivement s'assurer que les
frontières entre la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale et loi de finan
était strictement respecté et lonam fait
figure de bon élève sur sur ce sujet par
rapport par rapport à beaucoup d'agences
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que je peux
vous permettre juste il nous reste 5
minutes pour répondre à notre collègue
madame guottin concernant l'intelligence
artificielle c'est un sujet complètement
nouveau c'est c'est c'est c'est un sujet
complètement nouveau on a aucun recul à
aujourd'hui sur sur ces aspects je
dirais l'intelligence artificielle pose
des questions totalement inédites sur
qui est responsable de quoi le
concepteur celui qui commercialise celui
qui utilise c'est des questions inédites
nouvelles un peu comme le covid dans
l'établissement de santé je pense que on
va être les premiers nous dispositifs
amiables à à être amenés à se prononcer
sur ces sujetsl ce qui était le cas
c'est les les commissions de
conciliation et d'indemnisation avant
toute première décision devant les juges
administratifs ou juges judiciaires est
amené à se pencher sur cette question
d'infection nosocomiale en établissement
de santé à l'occasion d'une crise
épidémique et bien s l'intelligence
artificielle je je pense qu'il y a des
questions d'une redoutable complexité
qui sont devant nous al encore une fois
chaque fois c'est il y a pas de réponse
générale ça va être dans les
circonstances de particulière des
dommages de questionner qui est
responsable de
quoi très bien merci beaucoup Monsieur
le Directeur Général pour ses pour ses
réponses donc nous clôuré donc je vous
rappelle hein on a eu l'occasion de vous
entendre vous intervenez demain à
l'Assemblée nationale il n'y a pas de
vote hein c'est une nomination en tous
les cas merci de n avoir fait ce point
d'étape donc vos travaux et puis nous
continuerons à vous auditionner au fur à
mesure voilà mes chers collègues nous
allons clôturer je vous rappelle que
pour pour les pour les nouveaux il y a
le la simulation desméire juste après et
puis sinon pour les autres on se
retrouve demain matin à 8h30 pour
l'audition du directeur général de
laacnam voilà merci
beaucoup